Speaker 1: I sadly am going to discuss an
interview from CNN's new Kaitlan Collins show
that is indicative of how far the United States
of America has fallen, specifically with regard
to that other party, the Republican Party,
and what they now defend and support. There
is a senator named Tommy Tuberville. Tuberville, I
keep hearing his name pronounced multiple ways. I
don't know Octubre. Let's go with Tuberville for
today. And then tomorrow we'll say Tuberville.
He was on CNN's The Source. This is Kaitlan
Collins, his new show, and it debuted last
night. And he was asked about an interview that he
gave NPR back in May. And during that interview,
when he was sort of confronted with his seemingly
lack of opposition to white nationalists. He said,
listen, white nationalists are Americans at the
end of the day. And Kaitlan Collins did something
interesting, which is she gave him the opportunity
to explain, clarify and expand on those comments.
And Tuberville actually made it worse. I am the
the lens through which I am suggesting you watch
this interview is that this is now the Republican
Party. Where we are is playing footsie with white
nationalists. And he actually at one point says,
I don't know that white nationalists are racist if
they're racist, I'm against that stuff. But
that's an opinion that white nationalism is
racist. Let's start with the first clip. This
is this is sad as much as it is outraging.
Speaker 2: I do want to give you a chance to
clarify some comments you made recently on
white nationalists serving in the
military. For those who are watching,
if they haven't heard your remarks, this is what
you said. Do you believe they should allow white
nationalists in the military? Well, they
call them that. I call them Americans.
Do you want to explain those
comments, Senator? Yeah. First of all,
I'm totally against any type
of racism. Okay. As a football.
Speaker 1: Good to mention that.
Speaker 2: Coach for 40 years and I
dealt and had opportunity to be around
more minorities than anybody up here.
Speaker 1: Did you guys catch that little
slip? Okay, so there's two layers to what you
just said. And I sort of stepped on it. So we're
going to go back and listen again in argue in in
in order to prove how not racist he is. He goes, I
was a football coach. Okay. So he's saying I dealt
I dealt with he actually these what I dealt with
black people and then he catches himself dealt
with sounds like it's a little bit negative.
I had to deal with the burden of black people.
And then he goes, you know, I and
so we had every minority. It's
actually stunning that this quickly it implodes.
Speaker 2: He says, okay, I was a football coach
for 40 years and I dealt and had opportunity.
Speaker 1: I dealt with. That sounds bad.
I had the opportunity to have
minorities. Okay, let's continue.
Speaker 2: To be around more minorities
and anybody up here on this hill. Yeah,
but when our military has been attacked, was being
attacked after 911, after January six, and that
was my first day on the Senate floor, I thought
it was I thought it was outrageous what senators
from the Democratic side, Chuck Schumer, said.
Speaker 1: So this is, of course, not an answer.
Speaker 2: Law that night, calling
out people, calling people racists,
calling people nationalist, white, nationalist,
white nationalist is just another word that they
want to use other than racism. I'm totally against
anything to do with racism. But the thing about
being a white nationalist is just a cover word for
the Democrats now where they can use it to try to
make people mad across the country. Identity
politics, right? Totally against that. But
I'm for the American people and for can.
Speaker 1: You imagine not wanting white
nationalists in the military is now identity
politics. That is really something else. And
then when Caitlin Collins really gets to
the critical part of this, which is white
nationalists are racist, that's that's what
makes the if you're a white nationalist and
you get rid of the white nationalist beliefs,
you're just white, you're no longer racist. The
racism is in that white nationalism. He goes,
Well, that's your opinion, Caitlin, because.
Speaker 2: You said a white nationalist
is an American is identity politics and a
white nationalist is an American. But a white
nationalist is someone who who believes horrific
things you don't Do you really think that someone
who should be serving in the military? Well,
that's just a name that has been given. I mean,
it's not personal. It's a real definition. There's
real concern if you're going to do away with most
white people in this country, out of the military,
we got huge problems. It's not a huge problem.
Speaker 1: Is he saying that most white people
in the military are white nationalists
and therefore, if you got rid of the
white nationalists in the military, you'd have
no white people left at all? Is that what this
guy's saying? He's digging the hole deeper
and this is the Republican Party or white?
Speaker 2: It's white nationalists that
have a few probably different beliefs,
right? They have that have different beliefs. Now,
if racism is one of those beliefs, I'm totally
against it. I am totally against racism. But that
is a lot of people that believe everything is
racist. Senator. Well, that's your
opinion. That's your opinion with
racism. If it's racism, I'm totally against it.
Speaker 1: So, listen, the three main ideas of
white nationalism are, number one, white people.
And by the way, it's always real white people,
right? Like it's it's European, white, a
European-Americans, white people. White people
are threatened by race, mixing multiculturalism,
immigration of brat, black and brown people,
the low birth rates of whites, etc.. That's
one belief. That's a racist belief. Number two,
white people should be seeking some kind of a
white only state, a white ethno state to preserve
racial purity and identity. That's belief number
two of white nationalists. And number three,
typically white people are also superior to
non white people. Now, sometimes they they
know that that one's not as palatable as some
of these other. So they'll stop. Short of that,
they go, listen, I don't have to weigh in
on whether white people are superior or not.
But we should certainly be separate for sure.
Those are if you remove the white nationalism,
then it's no longer white nationalism. And
what Tommy Tuberville is saying, of course,
doesn't make any sense. This is where we are in
2023. Republicans multiple times, even when given
the opportunity to clarify, restating that white
nationalists are simply Americans maybe whose
views differ, but they aren't necessarily racist.
And of course, part of this is this environment in
which Trump has sort of normalized. You never back
up, you never backpedal, you never apologize. And
in a sense, I understand the reason for that,
because if that's the way Trump sets the tone,
if these guys start apologizing and backtracking,
then all of a sudden they seem weak and they're
called debate and all of this different
stuff. But the problem, of course, is
that people sometimes do say the wrong thing. And
now that Tuberville is just doubling down on it,
it's really wild stuff. And we'll see what the
next follow up is on this, if there is any.